Điều đảm kéo sải hai dơ giữa tổng thông gà và đi miếp u進 và tổng thống pháp em,
mà nguyên mặt khóng, dính xa và thử điểm pen chốt.
Ní đang tái phân bộ một lực truy true đông.
Con u khuy này đối mặt với mùi cơ bị bỏ giới trong tính toán chính lượng phân tay.
Viet ngà pháp khởi động lại tiếp xúc cất cao.
Cho thấy cả hay bên đường những thứ xóo cần một lối thoát hỏi sao.
Sau hình bà nằm sau tranh cầm chương, mà chứ đặt sự đột phá.
Nếu các li lạc này được truy true, bà tích bản của thử diễn xa,
một lạ đối thoát ngà pháp trở thành bàn đáp,
cho đàn phán sợng hơn với li mình châu Âu,
nhằm định hình chật tự ăn li mình châu Âu hậu chiến.
Hãy là pháp đồng phá trở trung xan,
để xuất lộ trình hoa đình chung lập,
khi nền tên và phá trở sân xác của Mỹ đang sạm xuất.
Bà lạ li lạm chỉ măng tính biểu tượng,
nhưng cũng đủ đẻ anh yết các thần trong ngã hạn,
và tạo ra khoảng lặng trước các bên tái đánh giá trí lửa.
Trong tình hình thế chẳng đăng thay đổi,
đất thái của Mosqueva và Pah Rý có thể là bức đau chú một tiến trình
sẽ quyết quan trịn hơn,
nếu các bên đủ kinh nhãn và sẵn sản dựng bộ.